how y'all doing listen so two years ago
I was forced to move to New York because
of success and I hate that place
oh Jesus I hate that place because god
forbid when the Yankees finds out I'm
not from there oh so I'm at the bodega
near my house standing in line for doing
one of those ecoli sandwiches and a
woman behind me goes what's happening to
me right now just another wonderful day
in New York she's like where are you
from you don't sound like you're from
New York cuz they all sound like witches
to me it's like no ma'am I'm from the
south
what do you mean you're not from New
York ma'am there are 49 other states
well I mean what are you doing here
ma'am I'm just trying to get one of
these dangerous sandwiches how can I
help you well you must be so glad to be
in New York why the hell would I be glad
to be in New York what a South is so
racist the south is so racist oh you
mean the part of the South that starts
at Canada and ends at Mexico
last time I checked America's race that
she goes yeah right and then she hobbled
out of this bodega but this is the thing
I know the North is more racist than the
North Face foot up white folks they got
Irish neighborhoods Italian
neighborhoods I live in a Greek
neighborhood what kind of deep cut of
white is Greek where did you get these
people you know what they call Irish and
Italian and Greek in the south white
nobody cares I don't care what flag
you're Caucasian flies under go buy a
house and sit down Brandon don't nobody
here now since I've been in New York
I've been single which is confusing cuz
you see welcome I grew on myself so I've
had to take some drastic measures you
know cuz I I've been out here peeping
these men's it's you know what I mean do
I remember that movie the predator you
see a targeting him numbers come up on
the side that's your girl how you doing
black shirt listen I'm a problem of an
out here peeping these men paying real
close attention I was out the other
night and I was like oh he's cute wait a
minute is he paying for cheap beer with
wet money why is the money wet his pants
are dry I don't want to know wait you
over here okay hold on
see bowlegged pigeon-toed what is this
broken cowboy in the streets no not you
either okay how are you
mm-hmm well-groomed nice outfit
starting to tab my favorite thing so I'm
moving closer to get some more details
and boom wedding ring
how dare you give me hope you see if I
see a ring on a man he might as well be
invisible outline of a human Peter Pan's
shadow with you will I can't use that's
stupid
now used to live in LA cuz Jesus loves
me
thank you so much thank you so much
[Applause]
but this is the thing my first couple
months here I didn't see any black
people which was very confusing cuz like
wait a minute I know they're here I seen
him on TV where'd you put him but the
problem was I lived in East LA in a
Mexican American neighborhood that was
quickly getting gentrified and neither
group of people could figure out my
black ass was doing there and then I
speak Spanish so the Mexicans thought I
was a spy
cuz like no I just found the most
efficient way to order nachos I passed
or porfavor gracias
I do what I can for nachos please know
that about me but the most suspicious
were Latino lyft drivers because my name
is duals they have a Spanish name so
they see Dulce on the phone but then I
get in the car so he's like I get in he
goes dude yeah
so like where are you from Atlanta nah
where's your mom from Miami
nah where's your grandma from dude take
me home man I'm not here for you lift 23
of me Jorge
take me to home
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]